you know this has probably gotten talked
about to death but I still feel like
giving my opinion on it anyway so here
it goes
Batman The Killing Joke is one of the
most iconic and groundbreaking Batman
stories ever told
and any adaptation should draw at least
a little inspiration from it hell it was
such a milestone for Batman stories that
Tim Burton used it as a direct source
for his movie that came out the same
year
I'm sure you could be a dick and say
it's overrated and it's really easy to
say that about anything well respected
and popular but I think this story for
as succinct as it is pretty much
deserves the praise and how cool would
it be to have it brought to life on
screen with Kevin Conroy and Mark Hamill
reading off such character defining
dialogue that was the goal that Bruce
Timm set out for and I would say that he
kind of got there kind of kind of there
have been a lot of animated adaptations
of great Batman stories over the years I
think of all of them this was the one
that I was most excited for and sadly
the most letdown bike so without really
rambling any further let's get right
into it yes that first 30 minutes was so
unbelievably unnecessary and it wasn't
necessarily awful but God did it feel
out of place it's just a lot of filler
to get this story to feature-length and
it's hardly on par with the writing with
the rest of the story what struck me
about it while watching in the theatre
yes I saw this in the theatre was that
it felt like a random one-off episode of
the Batman animated series granted it
had blood cussing and sex but it just
felt like a really hard edge episode of
the old cartoon and it wasn't a
particularly good episode either I
remember people in the theater were
squirming in their seats having side
conversations or just straight up
leaving during this segment because it's
not what they came here to see in order
to have anything to do with the entire
rest of the film it feels like you can
pinpoint the exact cut when the actual
movie should have started and here right
here that's when the movie should have
started everything in this segment of
the movie damages the rest of the
material by hanging off of it like a
tumor there's ham-fisted dialogue that
makes an attempt
set up the rest of the movie there's the
awkward side characters that never show
up again from this point forward and
then there's this romance subplot you
see I have a theory that Bruce Timm has
always shipped Batman and Batgirl but
never got a chance to make that
relationship official and his DC
Animated universe but spring break will
be coming up soon and I'll be back in
Gotham for two whole weeks
will that be nice cuz if you had I'd be
really upset cuz I thought you and I
were you know there's hints at it and
mystery of the Batwoman mask of the
phantasm and Batman Beyond and the
Batman Beyond 2.0 book just straight-up
says he got her pregnant and had a huge
fight with Nightwing about it now Bruce
Timm the rule 34 drawing man we all know
and love is producing a whole movie
where they felt like they had a whole
extra 1/2 hour to fill up and him and
the writer Brian Azzarello felt it
necessary to include their fanfiction in
the empty space the way they explained
it away also has so many flaws that I
don't even want to get into it but let's
do it anyway the reasoning behind is so
baffling and even borders on insulting
Bruce Timm made the argument that Batman
and Batgirl having a sexual relationship
made her injury more heartbreaking for
Batman and also further to his
motivation to go after the Joker what
they felt the need to spell it out for
the audience like that it doesn't take a
rocket scientist to understand that
Batman cares about his friends and
family and having them be a kind of sort
of couple only really ruins the power of
the story it was written to communicate
that Batman can't save people around him
from unprovoked tragedy especially when
they aren't in costume Barbara wasn't
targeted because she was Batgirl
she was targeted because she was
Commissioner Gordon's daughter and
served as a way to ruin his life to make
a point he was trying to hurt Batman by
going after Commissioner Gordon forcing
it down our throats that she was Batgirl
the whole first 30 minutes undermines
that idea that life can get [__] over
pretty hard by any random circumstance
her being back girl had nothing to do
with what happened in making such a big
deal out of it was honestly a pretty
dumb decision this whole debacle of an
opening basically just boils down to how
could two people care
about each other unless they're having
sex it also generally complicates the
relationship between all the characters
involved hey Jim I have nothing but
respect for you and you're one of my
best friends out there in this crazy
life of crime-fighting also I [__]
your daughter but best friends still
right now to be fair one could make the
argument that Batman sees a parallel
between his unhealthy relationship with
Joker and Batgirl stuff of Piper Paris
France I'm not here because of what was
found today I'm here because I need to
be
if there's any praise I can give this
it's that it gives Batman a concrete
reason for getting all sentimental and
wanting to go chat with the Joker
instead of just pounding his face in
because he sees what he could have
become given enough time and obsession
he realized he was building to the exact
same kind of breakdown there's also the
obvious parallel between Paris and Joker
both wanting desperately to have sex
with their bath themed counterpart could
all of this have been handled in a much
smarter way and in half the time yes yes
it could have is all of this needed to
tell this story no no it's not now aside
from the cringe-inducing be plot there
seems to be a lot of minor notes in the
story that were inserted to add to the
running time like for example okay
there's this short scene where Batman's
trying to track down the Joker and they
make the accusation that every time he
breaks out of prison he goes to the
shady part of town to pick up
prostitutes they didn't need to be in
there doesn't add or detract anything
except confusing the narrative with
details that ultimately don't matter and
seem just as out of character as Batman
and Batgirl doing it on a rooftop for
the whole world to see I mean yes
there's a panel from the book
corresponding to each of these scenes
but it was presented as a short montage
with no dialogue
and gave this idea that Batman didn't
even know what to look for and felt
hopeless until Joker just straight-up
told him where to go
I think the downfall of this whole
adaptation is just unnecessary additives
because the story is only fifty pages
but did it need to be that long
what stopped this from being a one-hour
special like that Superman inch to Zam
animated movie I don't think anyone
would have complained if it was more
straightforward and told the story as it
was of all the Batman animated movie
this one just feels the weakest I'd say
my personal favorite was probably under
the Red Hood the thing that struck me
about that film was that it didn't feel
the need to add to the story but instead
cut things that complicated the
narrative or felt unnecessary it felt
more self contained in the book the
scenes where Batman wanders around
talking to random superheroes about
coming back from the dead the part about
Clayface pretending to be hush
pretending to be Jason and Bludhaven
getting nuked in the middle of the
climax of the book were all things that
didn't need
they're in the movie opted to just
ignore them I prefer that version in the
movie to the book because the themes hit
harder and the plot is less cluttered
with outside [__] from the DC Universe
seeping in and distracting you
killing jokes animated movie is the
exact antithesis of this and it
shouldn't have been that way it's
stuffed with excess and the question
becomes could you when it should have
been should you the action scenes feel
out of place in awkward because this
isn't really an action story the
narration from Batgirl appears only only
half of the movie and didn't say
anything we didn't already understand
from the visuals and the musical number
is just uh you know Mark Hamill is a
talented guy he has some intense range
with things he can do as the Joker from
kitty and silly to dark and sadistic and
this was one moment that did not require
Kitty and silly the song in the comic
didn't have a tone and could have been
interpreted a lot of ways but I think
slow and creepy would have fit best with
the scene which Mark Hamill can do in
shades just look at the credits for
Batman Arkham City where he sings only
you
[Applause]
[Music]
and the images of them dancing on the
screen could have just been random
footage he had from beforehand instead
of fully choreographed dance sequences
the mind the scenes footage has the
musical directors talking about how they
wanted the scene to have an upbeat song
with horror elements because he's a fan
himself he understands how people
generally feel about the Joker and who
they think the Joker is that in the
context of the movie this was going to
be the most horrific part of the movie
just because the lyrics are grim doesn't
mean it's a sad song just listen to the
Elton John song about suicide the song
doesn't make you feel depressed or
disturbed the juxtaposition of this
happy song with the bloody visual
doesn't work it destabilizes the tone
and this scene doesn't hit as hard as
when you're reading it alone to yourself
quietly without sounding too [__]
I want to bring up that I came off of
this being very happy with the flashback
scenes - one of Joker's supposed origins
these scenes were brilliantly accurate
and they really showcased Mark Hamill's
ability to turn his persona on a dime
sounds like such a troubled normal guy
in the events in the ace chemicals
Building are very intense and traumatic
it's probably my favorite rendition of
this scene ever from the 1988 film to
the Red Hood version - the Arkham
origins perspective all the way to Scott
Snyder's version of it in zero year I
think this one hit the mark perfectly
and I just wish the rest of the movie
can meet the standards set by this scene
the story itself is chock-full of
problems but I think something else that
holds it back is the animation there are
a lot of spots where it looks a little
wonky or just boring to watch I think
the matter isn't helped by the fact that
this clearly tried to mimic the art
style of the deluxe edition of Killing
Joke where they basically removed all
the color and everything looks dry and
dull as opposed to the flashy and
stylistic colors of the original version
of the book someone on YouTube even went
so far as to reanimate the trailer to
look like the book version of that and
that's far more pleasant to watch go
check out that video that guy did great
work on the ending feels appropriately
abrupt for the story and I appreciate
the voice acting most for this scene
seeing Batman and Joker stop and have a
normal conversation like two regular
people was so unique for this story and
Kevin and Mark did a fantastic job
reading it I think the only thing they
could have changed was trying to play up
the ambiguity of the ending the idea of
the ending is more that you can't tell
if Batman reaches over and kills the
Joker or not maybe he just puts his hand
on his shoulders and then pulls him into
the approaching police car
maybe he grabs him by the neck and snaps
his spine because he's cackling like a
madman and really lost it maybe it's
somewhere in between where he beats the
ever-loving [__] out of him and lets the
police cart him off the movie version
wasn't directed in a way that shows that
any of these were really the way it
could have gone and I think with some
slight editing it could have the same
impact
now let's ruin it by adding an upbeat
after credits scene to show Oracle for
no reason
right then back to work
oh come on okay if you wanted to add
things I'd say add scenes with Joker
maybe explore how he ended up in the
prison this time show how he escaped in
switched places that random guy maybe
show him finding his inspiration for
this plan maybe even talk about his
previous acts of violence and talk about
Jason Todd's death little if there's any
one character that they should focus on
it's the Joker not Batman not Batgirl
not [__] Paris Franz
well that's too uploads in a week no way
it's actually yeah yes way Paul thanks
to the help of my guest editor on this
video my lovely girlfriend Anna I sent
her on the porn oh is she just the
greatest but don't go anywhere yet I got
something to tell you you guys like
merch we got merch look we got shirts
hoodies tank tops crop tops v-necks if
your hipster phone cases pillows coffee
mugs tote bags baseball shirts laptop
cases stickers and baby onesies not I'm
not doing a bit this isn't a joke this
is real go check it out I had help
putting it together from these lovely
people if demand is high enough will
even start adding even more designs on a
pretty consistent basis and do stuff
like posters and prints too and if you
liked this video you can support me on
patreon where I do behind-the-scenes
videos and post polls for viewers okay
I'm done advertising now bye love you
[Music]